uh
yes we're live now so you can start the
meeting thank you
thank you uh good morning and welcome to
the overview and scrutiny one committee
all participants are taking part
remotely and we are live streaming to
youtube
there will now be a roll call for
confirmation that members of the
committee
are present you could do the wrong call
please chris
yep councillor clarence uh president
councillor d cox president
uh councillor foden presents
councillor hocking
and then i have apologies from
councillor eden
councillor gribble and council malone
isn't present i don't think his
councilman lone here
no okay that's that's fine thank you
chair
thank you um right the announcements
please
make sure all microphones are muted when
you're not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels
please keep your point
short and do not interrupt when someone
is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic hand and wait to be called
when it comes to a vote if we are to
roll call the democratic services
officer
will read our members names
would members please say if they're
voting for against or abstaining
alternatively the vote will be taken by
a show of hands
we will look to have a break at a
convenient time some 90 minutes into the
meeting if required
if members lose internet connection the
meeting we
will be paused for a few minutes to
allow members to rejoin
moving on to the agenda agenda item one
are there any apologies please
trish yes thank you apologies from
councillor eden gribble
and malone's not present thank you thank
you
um agenda i am present i'm right here
oh sorry thank you
um to
the minutes of the last meeting um
first i'm quite happy with them i
propose to
accept them if i could have a second up
or any comments thank you in a second
thank you anyone disagree with that
could we do that on a show of hands
rather than a roll call please
it's fine chairs are there any against
and any abstentions
um item three are there any declarations
of interest please
don't think so um
right item four are there any public
questions please
trish no public chair
um public questions chair thank you and
are there any counsellor questions
no okay probably item
six uh executive forward plan
um i think we just need
to note that unless there's any comments
on that one
no i don't think so can't yes thanks
chair that's just to note the um
executive full plans available for the
link in the agenda
yeah okay um item
seven work program uh again just like
to note that i believe unless there's
any comments on that
no okay noted
uh item ever eight connecting devon and
somerset scheme
welcome to matt barrow from devon county
council who will update us on the
committee and ask
questions in conjunction with the neil
blaney head of place in commercial
services and councillor martin wrigley
executive member um yep carry on with it
cheers lovely thank you chair
um neil charles i assume you're happy if
i take the lead initially okay
great so just have a
slideshow which i'd like to run through
really essentially um bringing up speed
and looking at forward plans over the
next couple of years
um forgive me i didn't introduce myself
my name's matt barrow i
am the stakeholder engagement officer
for connecting devon and somerset so
it's my role to work with
individuals communities parishes uh
councillors at a district and county
level as well as constituency offices
and act as the the link between the uh
programme
and the communities that we serve um
forgive me for some of you will be
familiar with um some of this background
but i think it is important just to
provide
a context um going forward i'll
try and be concise but um as colleagues
who do know me
will know that brevity is perhaps not my
strong suit um i'll be as quick as i can
so essentially connection governance
somerset we're a partnership program
partnership of
local authorities the lep and
national government and we exist to
deliver the government's superfast
agenda so we are about
raising speeds across the cds region
um which encompasses the geographies of
uh devon and somerset's county councils
as well as the
unitaries to the north and we're about
bringing people up to
at least speeds of 30 meg per second
that's the the definition of uh
super fast and sorry i thought my slides
would stop working
um and the the objectives are fairly
clear we are about business support
we're about community support
as well as the the transformation of uh
the public sector
um and critically we operate
in those areas whether it's deemed to be
market failure so essentially
we talk to industry and we identify
where it is there
they believe is commercial for them to
roll out
connectivity across the region um and
where they are going commercially we do
not go
this is about state aid clearance and
ensuring uh the best use
of public the public purse um
essentially by and large what that means
around
economies of scale is that we operate in
the rural parts of the cds region
and industry will commercially deliver
into the more
urban parts so the definition of
commercial failure is a double-edged
sword on the one hand it would mean that
essentially industry would not be going
to those more rural parts
but it does then give us state aid
clearance to allow us to intervene
and pay industry to go to those places
that they do not be commercially viable
we operate in phases our phase one was
delivered um
exclusively and indeed nationally was
delivered exclusively
uh with bt and the overall budget as a
combination of
uh public sector funding and
the monies contributed to contracts by
industry you can see was 94 million
um we are now operating within phase two
and that combined total is around 78
million
so essentially the first phase contract
was um delivered as i say nationally by
bt i think exclusively um and our phase
two i'm not glossing over the fact many
of you will be familiar that um
our first contract for phase two were
originally left with a company called
gigaclear um and i will come on to that
so this bullet point doesn't address
that but as i say i'm not glossing over
it
um but we recently announced just before
christmas about as close to christmas as
you can possibly get
um that we had re-let those contracts
over the region with
three firms and wessex internet and true
speed
so on phase one um we delivered
as the state-funded element um
approximately 300 000 premises of which
270 odd at the the time of um
contract closure were delivered at a
super fast speed
the remaining 30 000 had a significant
uplift
but they didn't quite hit that um super
fast definition
so it was a significant benefit but it
was
perhaps uh an unintended consequence it
was a bonus if you like
um we then uh let some of our phases to
money early in a contract to deliver
into
the two moors um and that was
essentially because we'd identified in
discussion with industry
but whatever we did with our phase two
contracts given that they weren't going
to
cover the totality of the region it
became pretty obvious
where was going to be the last place um
that
our contractors were likely to go so we
decided to bite the bullet and address
those first
and we delivered over 5000 properties
in iran dharma and export um we ran our
own voucher scheme which was an interim
measure and was around getting people
who suffered the
the absolute slowest speed some kind of
uh
interim um uplift and relief on their
speeds
predominantly delivered through um 4g
technology um and this
the bullet says 1 300 installations i
think we ended up probably delivering
closer to
1 600 or so and then under phase
two of the six lots that we let five
were left with giga clear one was left
with
air band and that was the lot four area
um
and this is uh will be significant as we
go on but essentially that was for
north devon torridge and west evan um
with
some 13 13 to 14 000 properties
delivered
initially um using superfast wireless
um as a rapid deployment methodology
but within the contract um airband
approaches
after about a year's operation they as a
company were moving more into fiber
and the the latter part of that contract
we'll be delivering
delivered using fibre and it's it's
important to emphasize that because
we spend quite a lot of time working
with our band on the the moors contract
um explaining to people the benefit of
fixed wireless
and i think um perhaps we've almost made
a rod for our own back in
associating um airband's name with
wireless deployment wallace is an
excellent technology but the new
contracts
will all actually be fiber in parallel
we worked with giga clear for a period
of time but ultimately those contracts
were not successful um and they were
cancelled
in september of 2019
so we then had to go through a process
of reprocuring those
and it is uh it is a long process it's
not one that you can take any
uh any shortcuts over but i'll take you
through that but
um on the 23rd of december last year we
were successful
in signing uh six contracts
um including the lot f contract
uh which impacts on tinbridge um and
that was delivered
uh sorry that was awarded to two airband
so looking at the coverage that impacts
on the district the first
um phase operating with bt used the
technology called fiber to the cabinet
where essentially we were building out
from their existing infrastructure
vibes the cabinets are i said in some
respects a self-explanatory term you run
fiber to the existing green roadside
boxes
you erect another box you tie the two
together but the
last journey of the delivery of
broadband runs on the existing copper
wires
so this is um it's an excellent
technology
in urban areas um if you have 400
properties connected to
a green box and you enable that for
fiber 400 properties
you get access to super fast as a
technology will deliver
up to 80 meg per second but
uh copper being a metal metal having
resistance
speed attenuates over distance so the
easiest way of thinking of it is if
you're within approximately
1.2 kilometers of a green box and you're
attached by copper
you will get a super fast speed if
you're next to the box you'll get 80
and as you get further out your speed
drops round about 1.2 kilometer
it drops below that super fast mark so
essentially with bt we didn't
pay them once the speed had dropped
below super fast speed
however between 1.2 and 1.8 kilometers
you still can get a significant
improvement
over your existing standard copper speed
so you might go
from 5 meg to 18. so there's a lot of
benefit and
and what this diagram shows and the um
the mapping on this program is is always
slightly tricky
but the the heat map areas
the green inner circles represent the
1.2 kilometer radius
and then the purple fringes represent
the 1.2 to 1.8
so that's where the coverage mainly
impacted
under under phase one um you then
saw some benefit coming in from the
mullen contract with airband and this
kind of represents
um the coverage patterns
that they were then able to introduce
and
increase coverage within the district
using predominantly fixed wireless
at this point so if you look between the
two
um there is there is a there are kind of
two sides of the coin if you like
just briefly on the giga clear contracts
um we
originally let those uh at the tail end
of 2016 and they were due to run 17 18
and 2019 with a target of around 41 000
premises across the region
um and they they were beset with
a number of difficulties in 2018
um gigaclear i identified that they were
struggling
um and provided us with information on
some of those issues
which we worked together with them on um
and and to be fair had been working with
them on some of these issues prior to
that point
um and they revolved around a number of
things um they were
impacted by the collapse of carillion
talent who were their
uh tier one subcontractor and slated to
deliver the vast majority of their build
obviously with that company going under
there was then a period of
uncertainty talent stepped into the
breach under
um a kind of joint user agreement
between carillon and talent
but that that was a significant impact
there were also issues around designs
which didn't really scale from where
they'd operate in other parts of the
country
and they didn't really mesh particularly
with southwest geographies
um they did introduce significant
additional funding they were
bought out by a venture capital firm
in for capital who introduced more
funding into the the program
and they significantly increased their
regional capacity both within the team
um and their subcontractors
and but all of this took time and
impacted on their ability to deliver
and they revised their plans on a number
of occasions and that is a
formal process within the contract so
they had remedial plans
several several reiterations of those
but but ultimately they were
unsuccessful
so the contracts were terminated in
september of 2019
and we began the the arduous route of
replacing those
um and it's never as simple as just
going to somebody else
um and we did have to under our under
our state aid terms
um have to go back out to a full
procurement
so the procurement ran along these lines
there were decisions that needed to be
taken as to what kind of procurement and
we did have a number of different routes
so we discussed those and took legal
advice and advice from our funders etc
during the early part of 2020 and then
embarked upon the
um the the chosen procurement route
um which i mean i won't take you through
but you can see that there are
there are stages which involve engaging
with industry getting an idea of their
their aspirations their appetite
and their capacity then inviting them to
complete an initial tender approach
which introduces a quality threshold and
bar
those potential bidders who met that bar
were then
invited to formally tender that then
takes you through an additional process
of evaluation and scrutiny of their
technical approach their financial
approach their legislative professional
all that kind of stuff and then they had
to be assured and that was a joint
effort between
the cds team um and the
team at the department of cultural media
and sport
bd uk and ultimately we were successful
in signing all of those contracts there
was a degree of pressure
because we had a state aid regime that
was closing on the 31st of december
so had we not let the contracts before
that point it would not have been
possible
to let them in january um it was a go or
no-go situation so there was
an awful lot of relief around december
so for the next stages having let
the contracts um it kind of breaks down
into
five clear stages i think there's the
initial mobilization where
offices are established um staff
the the teams they have uh
all of these people have a core team in
in place to deliver but they need to
expand that so they're
finalizing recruitment and they're
finalizing
um the initial design so to
actually bid for these contracts there
needs to be
a basis for design and how the how the
rollout will happen
those designs need to be firmed up so
it's a firming up and getting ready
period
following that they need to survey and
design and strictly speaking it's
probably more design
survey and design um so the designs need
to be firmed up and then
the the assumptions within those designs
need to be tested
and that involves going out and
surveying within communities
checking that those things that they
think are there
are actually there finding unpleasant
surprises
rivers that aren't marked on maps
engineering difficulties and the like
those form the basis of survey packs
which are passed back into
the team and the designs are then
finalized
having done that there's then a phase
where all of the
um the requirements of those designs are
then planned
so highways notices or permits rather
need to be submitted
uh the way leaves that have been
identified within the surveying process
need to be acquired the
communities need to be engaged and told
what is about to
happen and subcontractors need to be
scheduled
and the build needs to be planned in
line with all of that um
that work um then
there's the build phase that's the bit
where you actually see boots on the
ground with people stringing fiber
clearing out ducts desilting replacing
telegraph poles cutting back trees
etc and then the final go live phase
on a sub-regional structure basis
um our contractors tell us that an area
is ready to go
we go out and do technical assurance
check that they have delivered to the
premises that they said they would
deliver to
using the right equipment that it's um
it's
what's called nga white compatible but
it's actually appropriate equipment
meanwhile they are testing they're
making sure that all of their
fiber splicing etc is ready to go and
then
the community is notified and people can
place orders so the coverage
overall um if you look uh you'll see the
purple purple purple shaded area
covers lot f it's a massive geography
for airband to cover
but they are enthusiastic and optimistic
and um that work will proceed
once that uh initial gearing up phase
uh is over and we will work with them
to engage with parish councils and
communities
to inform them about the first thing
that they will see which will be people
walking there walking their routes
walking their lanes
undoing the survey piece we've done
quite a lot
of this um over the last 12 months on
other
parallel contracts where we're working
with um both open reach and
abandon in other parts of the region and
we're acutely aware of the need to
engage with communities
to explain that so that surveying as a
process is coded safe
that colleagues doing that will actually
observe all the appropriate social
distancing
and are very alive to people walking
into their communities and
and any concerns that that may bring
the confidence that we have within our
new suppliers
are based on a number of the the points
which are which are kind of called out
here and then there are
there are perhaps differences with
previous contracts
um but but we have uh particular
confidence in these companies
for these reasons um they are
they're not open reach and there is
always a
a tendency for for one to kind of
compare with what we have known for
generations as the
the kind of incumbent telco but the
market
is uh increasingly a competitive space
um and there are large numbers of what
are called alt nets
smaller suppliers who are still
delivering at scale
and have been doing this for some time
so um each
each of our three contractors have been
around for about a decade
um they are they either are based within
the cds region
nearby or have a regional presence um
and they've got experience of building
within
the the cds patch they they know our
geographies
um and and have built at scale so
between them
they've already built around 45 000
premises across
the cds patch so they they have the kind
of quantum
um and track record uh that we're
looking for on these contracts
they've got staff in post they've got
staff you know the area
um and they have their commercial
investment already agreed so they have
serious backers from pension funds etc
and they've also
built to the satisfaction of government
on other bduk contracts
across the country and that last yellow
box
bottom right is quite a significant one
as
a an increasing change
that we're seeing within the industry so
pia is passive infrastructure access
and it allows for any
um telecom supplier who has what are
called code powers
to use other people's passive
infrastructure passive infrastructure
being
essentially ducts or telegraph poles so
be they
open reach western power and
distribution or
indeed each other's and that
significantly
potentially speeds the rollout so you're
not
talking about having to dig up every
kilometer of road that you need
to get down or erect your own telegraph
poles
you can use other people's and obviously
you can see how that would
massively help on a deployment of this
kind of scale
so within tinbridge the our records show
overall you have um just shy of 68
000 premises under phase one
cds delivered 21 000 and the commercial
sector delivered 35 again
roughly um split between rural and
urban um giving a total of
uh just over fifty six thousand or
eighty two percent
under our next phase we're looking at
5000 premises
being delivered by cds and i've noted
their gigabit capable and this is just
to underscore the point
that um airband coming from
um a background and being known as a
uk specialist in fixed wireless um have
moved into fiber over the last
12 to 18 months and all of these
properties will be delivered using fiber
rather than fixed wireless
in addition the commercial sectors
identified that they're going to do just
over a thousand properties
so that gives us just over another 6 000
to that remaining target and
that would give you coverage of just
over 92
across the district so that's up over
nine percent
um and those percentage points become
ever harder one as you can imagine as we
reach into
the harder to reach premises across the
whole
of the cds geography but that does give
us 5 000 premises
that for whom there is still currently
no plan and i'll come on and
address what we might do about those um
i know that you're clearly focused on
tinbridge but just as a kind of
overall state of the union slide we
started with
well we didn't start with a quantum of
one million one hundred thousand
properties we started with a quantum of
about a million properties but as the
cds deployment has
moved over the last seven or eight years
actually the the baseline has grown as
well with new houses being built
um houses uh moving from say
agricultural to residential
and and some significant refinement of
the data has seen that target grow
uh so it is a bit of a moving target the
more properties we deliver
uh the more properties seem to arrive um
but
that is where we are intending to be at
the end of these phase two contracts
that we will have delivered
over a million properties one million
fifty eight thousand
and that's around about 96 uh percent
of the total still obviously leaving
just under four percent
to deliver to
so the answers around properties who are
not
currently in plan um for whom there is
no
uh either commercial or state-funded
roll-out plan
um there are there are four ways of
addressing these and we will be doing so
in parallel with these funded contracts
so it's not a question
of let's wait and get to um 2023 2024
and then start to think about it so our
intention is very much to do this in
parallel
first of all we have our fiber extension
program and that's
primarily working with open reach uh
using funding uh so there's a funding
mechanism with all the within all of the
contracts that says
essentially that suppliers once their
take up
either customer base has increased above
a certain percentage as a result of
the upgrading of their infrastructure or
the paying for new infrastructure
then they are clearly achieving
increased profits
and a proportion of those are paid back
to the state in recognition of that
um so we are
we have a mechanism uh particularly that
addresses the the phase one contract
whereby open reach um pay us back on a
phased basis um the the difference
between
their target take-up and their actual
take-up
and that is that is uh not insignificant
so for example the um the original
target within the phase one contract
said that they would start paying back
once their take-up exceeded 20
of the premises attached to that new
network
um in reality in many cases and i think
averaged across the region
we are hovering at around 70 so there is
a significant difference between the
predicted
and actual take-up and that works very
much to
the taxpayers advantage those funds go
back
into um the delivery of
superfast broadband so it is a it's a
virtuous circle if you like
in parallel with that the government has
a rural gigabit voucher scheme
where communities can come together and
work with a telecoms provider to design
their own community solutions
and they do that based on voucher value
attributed to each property
which is around 1500 residentials 3500
for a business property and if you pull
together
40 or 50 properties you end up with um
a serious fighting fund
which is set at the right sort of level
um so it's an excellent fund and we are
seeing communities
across the patch including in tinbridge
um where
communities are going from we would like
to do something from ourselves
to actually delivering a full fiber
network for their community
and we exist to support that and that's
that's one of our key areas of work and
growth if you like
um and we do that in two ways one is um
in supporting the communities
introducing them to telecoms providers
helping them work their way through the
process
but we do also have a small amount of
money within our community challenge
program
so where there is a small gap um
your community might be light five
thousand ten thousand pounds
uh in some situations we can step in and
then
overlaying all of this um there is the
government's national fiber program
where in parallel with regional builds
um
to deliver on the superfast agenda there
is a national agenda of getting
a hundred percent of the uk connected
well
it has shifted slightly but essentially
the vast majority of the uk connected to
fiber
and that will come in in parallel with
us
to address many of those properties that
don't have superfast
as well as those properties that do have
superfast
but need to upgrade to fiber
and i think i'll leave it there because
my voice is going
thank you for that matt um
do we have any think from neil or martin
wrigley on that before we do questions
uh matt could you just give an overview
about the additionality
um from the team bridge contribution
towards this game
yeah absolutely so um tinbridge um
and it was very welcome contributed 250
000
into the overall uh contractual
um element for the last procurement um
it's it's tricky to disaggregate um
uh down to where were the properties
that this funded but i think i think
some of the the best ways of of looking
at things
are around the the uplift that that
resulted in
so if you look at um
if you look at the totality of
uh the the contract so 78 million pounds
and you look at the number of premises
that are being delivered which is around
56 000 across the region
you can actually come up with um a an
indication as to
what a property um roughly costs so the
average cost per
per premise which is around 1
300 pounds so that would
on your funding uh have contributed in
another 180 premises within um
within the tin bridge area but because
of your participation in the cds
procurement and the way those contracts
are let
which is on a collaborative model with
industry
um the the leveraging of
that funding is is around
45 state aid 55
um government uh sorry 55 commercial
so you can see that you automatically
more than double your premises
so that 180 would grow
to over 400 i think something like 420
425 premises um and that represents
even better value for money than than
you would have seen if you if you've
gone
into the market so you're you're easily
doubling your money and contributing
another
for 250 premises within the region um
i i think it is actually much broader
than that i think
the the fact that you've contributed
means that you are
active participants within the process
and you've had a hand
in the the procurement along the way um
have
approved the uh the setting of those
intervention areas for the lots and and
enabled
um and ensured that uh attention was
devoted and focused
on tinbridge and with a seat on the
board you get to
uh approve and and shape uh the way
these
these contracts function um and i think
that
probably also is represented
uh clearly in my mind by
the difference between the um the
premises that you would have achieved
under the giga clear contracts
which is around 1 400 and on
this occasion you're looking at 4
900 so you've you've increased
your coverage under these new framing of
the contracts
two and a half fold if you like um
so i think that again is is around um
influence and attention to uh the
district
um which which means that you know you
have done
uh perhaps rather better than some other
districts does does that answer your
question neil
yes thank you one more uh a couple of
went to chair
um for other members um information
the seat on the board that we have is
with councillor charles not all who's on
the call
today and also every quarter as part of
the report and on
the council strategy we do report back
on the progress
of the connecting them somerset project
which until
before christmas had stalled so we will
be keeping regular dialogue with matt
uh and members updates as to how the
program's rolling out
um we obviously this um video will be
available
for all those members who can't view it
um we are keen that
if any members would like to find out
more for their communities
and engage with that we will share these
slides in the members newsletter
but if you want to speak to myself or to
matt about
how your communities may engage with the
program further
then just let us know yeah absolutely
okay thank you very much um can we get
slides down now please
yeah absolutely
okay for questions for members because
i've got adrian
patch panda thank you chair
um i have i think had uh my main
question just answered which was
regarding how local communities can
engage
with um their or sometimes quite
pressing needs um
for broadband so so that question's been
answered but i just did have um
another question regarding one of the
maps in the presentation which showed a
purple area which i think was for
broadband across team bridge
and i did that appeared to be close to
the boundary with the dartmoor national
park
and i just wondered in terms of what air
band is doing
was that the boundary with the national
park or was that actually actually
the boundary of where their
infrastructure currently is
at the moment so the purple fringing
related to phase one so that's not
airband that would be open reaches
infrastructure
so that represents the the cabinet
infrastructure
we didn't with the money available
we chose those cabinets that delivered
the the most connectivity into rural
areas that we could possibly afford
so that mapping is not it's not
comprehensive
when it comes to open reaches
actual infrastructure it only represents
the
the infrastructure that cds funded to
upgrade um so in that sense is not
it's not at all reflective of um
airbands infrastructure it's only open
reach
okay thank you just finally just
following up on that given that phase
one there was a project
targeting dartmoor and exmoor um am i
right in thinking that
communities within dartmoor national
park are still eligible for assistance
through the schemes that you've outlined
yes absolutely so in in that sense um
i suppose we're quite quite binary if
you are not in receipt
of superfast then you qualify
for um support uh in in
varying different ways as outlined in in
in the presentation
um and and our focus is always on
community so the fact that
there was activity on dartmoor if if it
didn't affect your property
or your business then you remain
eligible significantly
um i suppose because we we currently
live in a kind of twin track world
whereby we are ever mindful
of the fact that there are properties
across the cds region particularly in
rural parts um that do not have
superfast
the fact that the the national drive is
to achieve
gigabit capable speeds with fiber
connectivity
um we need to
protect against the situation where
essentially that whole drive then starts
again from
from the market towns and cities within
the region
and starts rolling out full fiber to
those people who will already have super
fast speeds
and we need to focus on rural areas
however
the way that the the funding for
a lot of fiber deployment
is is approved
it means that actually for those
properties that
do not currently have a hundred meg per
second
you would qualify for the rural gigabit
voucher scheme
so there are some situations undoubtedly
where there will be communities that
have arguably
reasonable speeds and the kind of speeds
that some people could only dream of
but want more and want fiber they would
be eligible
under the the government's voucher
scheme to upgrade themselves
our focus needs to be around those
premises
that are still languishing at
subsuperfast which is not to say that we
wouldn't help another community
but i suppose we we have to prioritize
those communities that are sub superfast
but the mechanisms for doing so
are now gigabit capable so all of the
work that we are putting into
communities that might only be getting
to meg will
raise them to potentially up to a
thousand meg per second they will be
gigabit capable
okay thank you very much and thank you
for a very interesting presentation
pleasure thank you
councillor david cox please thank you
very much i
i do notice an awful lot of people are
moving to um
to devon and to team bridge from london
um i guess they're taking the view that
as they can work from home now they
might
live by the sea or on the malls uh
a lot of them will take uh the internet
for granted and of course they won't
won't no is this going to affect plans
at all or is this is this is
in any way going to affect people who
are going to relocate their businesses
to the middle of the moors
because they can work remotely because
they don't realize that they haven't
probably got the internet that they've
got in central london
i think increasingly um estate agents
on online online estate agents places
like zupla
will always quote internet speeds as as
one of those
key pieces of information that there has
been a change and
there were undoubted there was
undoubtedly a time where
that information wasn't as kind of front
and center
um as perhaps it might have been and and
clearly
within my role one of the things that i
deal with are uh queries and complaints
and
and we we did see in the past a lot of
people
who had purchased they had bought a
property and were then
appalled at their speeds that is that's
now
dropping off um and i think if people
are investing
you know a significant amount of money
um in relocating from another part of
the country
by and large they're tending to check on
on broadband speeds beforehand
but but it is clearly um a consideration
for anyone moving
um and the the faster that we can deploy
and ensure that
speeds are equitable and serviceable
across the region
and that that can only uh enhance inward
investment and people moving to the area
thank you very much thank you um
councillor john
nutley please
thank you chair and uh thank you mate
yeah very interesting presentation
um as you're probably aware excuse me um
probably where uh dartmouth national
park on
friday we approved an aerial uh new area
to go up near hong
kong mainly for emergency services uh to
when that's covered
um so that's that's some good news for
that area it's
like um adrian and david just said
obviously the moors
are pretty well affected um what i was
going to ask
do you do you become involved at all
after
insulation has been carried out if there
are any problems because
if you do i would like to ask the next
question
um so the answer is inevitably i suppose
um fundam
fundamentally if there are if there are
uh
tech support issues or issues around
outage you would you would
naturally take them up with your
internet service provider
um in the first instance but we have
um we have an interest in
uh and there are contractual
requirements that the
the networks that we pay to deliver um
continue to deliver the range and
quality of service that was
outlined in the original contracts so
that sounds really waffly please do ask
your next question
yeah i mean basically what it is i mean
i'm i live in ashburton
and uh we've been getting on to bt
because down through the
um east street one of the main streets
coming in through ashburton
the people down through there and i know
even across the other side of 38
one of my um council colleagues um
they've had awful problems especially
down e street and it appears that the
cable
down through there could be laying in
water
et cetera a lot of the time right which
is affecting though
whether that's anything you're in a
position to take up i don't know
um i'd need more details but i'd be
delighted to look into it if you can
either
either contact me directly or contact me
through neil
or uh councillor nuttal then then i'd be
delighted to take a look
i don't know whether that stretch
actually is part of the network that we
have funded
or not um but obviously we have we have
colleagues within openreach that we can
ask the question
of um and maybe apply a little bit of
pressure to
to get it looked into okay thank you
matt thank you
uh counselor mike hocking please
uh yeah thank you uh chair um a couple
of easy questions really all these
hopefully
um you said very early on in your
presentation and thank you for that as
well
um that you had 500 5000 applications
for um funding but you only
gave it to 1600 or you the projects only
went to 1
600. and can you tell us why
it was such a low
percentage that actually got the got the
help or got the
the project put through and then
secondly
um this super fast broadband that you
want about could you just remind us
exactly what speed that is again please
because
um i don't live that far from a green
box
um therefore it's and fiverr goes into
the box
but my my speed on average is around
about
2022 uh where i live
and in that the fact that as
this copper wire gets older and we're
some of
us are living in like uh early 70s
estates
and that this copper wire will start to
deteriorate and
at some point will have to be replaced
in order to
keep up the speeds and finally doesn't
the speed actually depend on the
on the broadband supplier um i mean i'm
with
um vodafone um obviously using a bt
system or at least a bt network
um let's say i'm getting about 20. i
used to be on virgin
which is obviously the true um fiber
um providers and again i wasn't getting
anywhere near
what they said that i should get um
and every time you said something about
it as oh well you know it's
it depends on demand etc etc
so there's a couple of little questions
i think just wants to clear up
some of the myths and that that surround
this high-speed broadband
yeah absolutely okay so i think at least
three questions
i'll try but you may have to remind me
um so you your first question is quite
simple and i
probably didn't um explain it very
clearly uh essentially
we we didn't decline any applications
and this is a voucher scheme that
there's probably three or four years old
we
didn't uh decline those uh so the the
five thousand dollar vouchers
were approved um what we're seeing is
uh the difference between those that
then ultimately went on
to take out a service arrange for an
installation
and i mean we know nationally within
voucher schemes
that the difference between people
expressing an interest
and actually finally going on to um
deliver a service that there's quite a
marked
uh kind of mark difference i think in
fact our
um our realization rate the number of
people who went on
to actually take out a service was much
much higher than
the the national average um and that's
that's a reflection
of of the need within the the cds region
i think typically a lot of other voucher
schemes the difference between
making an initial inquiry um and
actually
finishing at a point where you've got
somebody on the outside of your building
you know laying cables drilling holes
and putting up aerials uh
is about 15 to 20 so i think ours as was
close
to 30 to 40 so just just to clear that
we we didn't say
no to people um we we approved on the
uh the initial expression of interest we
just checked that they were
eligible under certain criteria that we
had and then awarded vouchers
but not everyone ultimately took them up
um
on the question around uh superfast
um so the definition has changed
when we were delivering um the phase one
program
the eu definition and therefore uk
definition
um was 24 meg per second
that has changed and there's been a bit
of realignment so it's now
30 it was 24 so essentially under phase
one um when open reach bt
um delivered a property that was 24 or
24 and a half
or higher that counted as them having
delivered
another property at superfast um below
that
uh as i said there were there were
you would feel if you'd been on two and
you were then getting 22
that that was a you know a significant
improvement
didn't technically qualify as super fast
but you are right there
there are there are gray areas and
margins so
it is entirely possible that the the
quality of your infrastructure
may may be degrading um the
the speed um and resulting in you
getting 22 when perhaps you should be
you should be getting higher i mean i'd
need to look into the specifics of your
properties
to see what actually you should be
getting um
open reach for example are now much
better at
providing indicative speed so they do
provide them
over a range and they do identify um
several different ranges and one is a
clean
if you like in a perfect world given
the distance your properties from um the
fiber-enabled cabinet
you should be capable of getting between
but it's still a range
so it's still between 16 and 23 or
between
18 and 26 or whatever and then they do
also provide
a in less than ideal situations if the
infrastructure is slightly older or has
been compromised in some respects
then then those speeds would be lower
but i'd need to i'd need to check
specifically as to what you should be
getting
and what you are getting because if you
should be getting
80 and you're only getting 22
that feels like something slightly more
fundamental than
just infrastructure which is aging
um and perhaps not delivering to 100 of
its capability
and i'm sensing that i've not answered
your third question
the third question was quite simply
doesn't some of the speeds and that
depend on the actual supplier
oh sorry yes absolutely yes of course um
so yes they do
um we we have some situations where
where
people are capable of getting super fast
but were unaware that they had to
order a new service so our um in some
cases can be languishing on
five meg when they could actually get 35
then it does depend on the internet
service provider that you contract with
and you will be contracting
for speeds at a certain level so the
fact that your connection is capable of
delivering 60 meg
if you take out a contract at a certain
level
which gives you um guaranteed inverted
commas speeds
on a range between 20 and 30
you are only ever going to get 30 even
though the infrastructure is capable
of delivering much faster so it can
depend
on what level of contract you have
actually taken out
and depending on the internet service
provider they may not have a product
that they are prepared to offer you
which does take advantage of the full
speeds that you could achieve
so they may not have a product that
would deliver you
60 meg they may have a cap at 50 and you
would then
actually need to shop around to find
another isp
who has a product that would take
advantage of that speed so
it's a combination of what the laws of
physics
dictate are possible for your property
combined with
um age of the infrastructure et cetera
but also
what you've what you've actually asked
for and paid for
thanks mike okay thank you that seems
i think that's all the questions now um
thank you very much
matt for your comprehensive um
presentation and answering all their
questions uh much appreciated
that's a pleasure thank you very much um
and yeah if if
anything occurs to you um laterally um
my contact details are readily available
and and i'm i'm here to answer your
questions so
um please don't don't hesitate to ask
but with that
thank you all for your time i'm aware
that i do bang on so i'm grateful for
your patience
um and i will i'll leave now
thank you thank you okay moving on
moving on to item nine
budget final financial plan proposals
i will ask executive member councillor
keeling to introduce the budget item
martin flipcroft chief
finance officer is in attendance and
will present the budget in more detail
i will then invite committee members to
ask any questions and then
the executive members to make any
comments the council will be considering
this item
at its meeting on the 22nd february
executive
on 11th february the recommendation from
this committee is set out
at agenda pages 17 and 18.
councillor keeling can i ask you that
you introduced the final budget
proposals thank you very much
thank you mr chair and thank you for
allowing me to bring the final budget
report
2021 to 22 and onwards
dear colleagues can i first pay tribute
to our staff
who have contributed to the savings made
some 2 million pounds
my thanks also to our chief financial
officer martin flincroft and his team
on the 4th of february we received the
final settlement from government
and there are no material changes
between the provisional
settlement i shared with you on the 12th
of january
and the final settlement for team bridge
district council now
colleagues i would like to bring to your
attention
the new homes bonus a new round of
allocations were announced in the
settlement
and we're in year 11 now these
allocations are a one-off
and will not attract future legacy
payments
in fact the written statement underlines
that this will be the final
set of allocations under the current
approach
are keen to replace the new homes bonus
and plan to consult
shortly on the future of it
also no guarantees are given about local
government funding reform we are still
expecting the reforms to be implemented
in 2223 but the government
written statement only comments to
revisit
the priorities for financial reform in
time for the next spending review
ministers will also be taking into
account wider work on the future of the
business rates
so our final budget proposal are to
update
are updated from the lockdown so no
significant changes
apart from a budget gap widening next
year to 1.2 million
so moving forward we expect next year to
be balanced
by earmarked reserves a budget gap of
1.2 million
22 to 23 and 2.8 million
23 to 24. so
councillors over the three years we have
a budget gap of
3.8 million pounds
we have managed to keep our capital
program unchanged
but we're just slightly scheduling
changes on dates
and we are also considering whether we
can reinstate
the 0.5 million pounds revenue
contribution from the reserves to
capital
and we will keep this as an option
so colleagues working together across
all political groups we can and will
make team bridge
into a green recovery and a sustainable
place to work
and live martin will now take you
through our funnel slide
and i'm pleased to see that chris
clarence is still here
and martin will give you some detail on
that
uh we're both to both be happy to answer
questions
afterwards at the end of martin's
presentation martin please
thank you so just a brief run through
the the budget report
as uh kealing has mentioned these are
the final budget proposals for
the years 21 22 going through to 23 24.
the figures in the report were based on
the provisional settlement
and we have now got the final settlement
with no changes for team bridge
and they go before parliament tomorrow
she should be approved tomorrow
what that also means as well is that
referendum limits are unchanged being
the higher of two percent or five pounds
the figures in the um final budget
proposals reflect the latest lockdown
no material changes to the capital
programme
and the final budget proposals also
include a mid-year review of treasury
management
which we're required to do under our
territory management code to be noted by
council
and some extra details in the appendices
around cost per service
area so just running through the key
recommendations again
a five pounds increase in cash flow tax
to 180 pounds and 17 pence
increasing climate change funding
continuing funding for enhanced planning
enforcement
maintaining revenue reserves at just
under 2 million pounds
increasing support for housing with the
team with 100
infrastructure delivery plan investment
continuation of the grant funded
southwest regional coastal monitoring
programme
and town center investment in
infrastructure and employment
section two of the executive report sets
the scene around reductions in
government funding
savings covered 19 impacts and the
inclusion of the team reached 100 in the
capital programme
together with provisions for climate
change projects and the future high
street funds bid
section 3 of the report provides more
detail on the savings made
to assist with the budget gaps that have
arisen i would point you to 3.3 in
particular
and the future costs impacting on the
council in 3.9
the mid-year review of treasury
management is in 3.11
section 4 covers the revenue budget at
appendix four
and fees and charges at appendix five
general inflation increases in both
charges um
across um the fees and charges piste and
some charges at newton market have been
frozen
having been reduced last year 4.2 to 4.4
gives more details on fees and charges
section 4 also looks at our proposed
change in council tax
and provides a
multi-year summary of how our funding
has changed from government to include
revenue support grant business rates
and new homes bonus a reduction of 35
percent
has occurred over that time period
the key paragraph is 4.27 and how we
have funded the budget gaps
we still have a budget gap of 1.2
million in 2223
and 2.6 million in 23.24
on top of that would be the aspirations
to put additional funds back into our
capital programme
of around about 0.5 million
failure to deliver savings obtain
greater funding from government
could trigger the issue of a section 114
notice in the future
section 5 includes details of the
capital program
again no material changes from the
initial budget proposals
and that's an appendix seven and as i
stated inclusive housing
via that team bridge 100 scheme climate
change infrastructure and employment
section 6 covers the consultation on the
budget proposals
and the outcomes of our budget survey
were reported to executive
on thursday and will form part of the
full council budget report via
an additional appendix so that's a quick
whip through the the report i'll also
now share my screen and go through a
funding chart which
in the past members have found quite
useful
and this is the latest version of it so
on this budget forecast we've got
both sets of revenue and capital funding
shown
the top half so if we go top half left
is the income that we get for the
revenue budget um
and then the green lines flowing below
are where that money is spent
so if you go around the chart
we start with um fees and charges at
10.5 million
um in the first grade circle on the
left-hand side just above the
big green line in the middle that covers
all our fees and charges from our
various sources like
leisure car parking planning etc
and we've got property income and
contribution from reserves
at 9.8 million that covers all the
property rents
recycling credits sales of recycling
material
and obviously to balance the books this
year 3.3 million from the contribution
from reserves
which is coming from earmarked reserves
casual tax income is there at 8.7
million
um that's our demand on um council tax
payers
and that percentage is um has
been reducing over the years it used to
be 11
um dipped down below 9
and is probably going to be closer to
eight and a half percent
um when we get the precepts from all the
other preceptors this year
the large one in the middle there is the
grants that we get
for other items
most of that is the grant for housing
benefit at 26.9 million
the money we get from business rates our
share is the 4.7 billion to the right of
that
revenue support grant um no zero that
used to be four and a half million
a few years ago and new homes bonus as
you can see is shrinking as well that's
down to 1.5 million now for new homes
that are built
so that gives us 62.1 million pounds
worth of
funding for the revenue budget and then
that flows out into those
light green arrows at the bottom of the
charts
you've got the first one leisure open
spaces and resorts
fairly self-explanatory 6.1 million
um a heading called governance
communications corporate services and
transformation at 4.8 million
that covers slt democratic services all
the main
support services um electoral services
internal audit finance hr members
allowances and procurement
and you've got other housing and health
services at 4.3 million
that covers housing environmental health
licensing and customer services
revenue and benefits are 26.2 million
the majority of that is the
housing benefits that we pay plus the
cost of the team for administering that
service
waste recycling and cleansing fairly
self-explanatory at 9.4 million
um strategic place services including
economy and planning at 9.2 million
that covers building control development
management parking economy
and spatial planning and then there's a
financing items which covers the
pensions
uh bank charges audit fees and uh any
contribution to reserves at 2.1 million
so that left hand side of that chart is
our revenue budget
and then the same procedure applies to
the right hand side which is our capital
budget
38.5 million again you can see the types
of funding at the top
and where that money is spent at the
bottom so a capital receipt
which is the money we get from um sale
of assets and right to buy money's
uh 2.6 million capital grants at 14.5
million
section 106 monies at 0.8 million
any schemes that require borrowing at
17.9 million
and still at 2.7 million again as that
flows through down to the bottom
um the spends are around 0.5 million
on it and central support services
flood alleviated alleviation and
environment at 5.5 million
that covers flood defenses coastal
monitoring
carbon management and climate change
open spaces and leisure at 6.9 million
covers
play areas sang sports centres cycle
paths and sports pitches
planning and development of 20.5 million
covers employment land
town centre regeneration and the hotel
developments
and then you've got housing grants and
affordable housing which includes the
the team bridge 100 the warm homes fund
private sector housing the dfg
type of thing so um
that's a quick whip around the
budgets that we've got um for next year
in terms of revenue
and capital i'm happy at that point to
take any questions thank you
thank you very much martin um
i can't see any questions actually
there was just one for me probably me
just not knowing nothing about this
in the revenue budget there's leisure
open spaces and resorts
6.1 and then in the capital as well
are they do they go to separate things
or is that all lumped in together
that makes any sense so the
the revenue cost is your um daily
running costs so that's a daily running
cost for the
leisure centre that's the staff um the
cost of running
um the the seafront activities and
results etc
um on the capital side that's um
any capital improvements that are being
taken place at those centres whether
that might be
new gym equipment or
improvements to the uh building itself
or the heating systems or that type of
thing
so what the left hand side revenue the
right and size capital so they are they
are distinct and separate
thank you um councillor mike hocking
please
yeah thank you chair uh sorry i couldn't
find me
button um yeah just a quick one really
um the nine point um
six million we got for um the high
street
it is that within the 14.5 million
on your um your your um
thing there your diagram and the
17.9 million of borrowing is that new
borrowing
or is that to help um
bring up the money that you're taking
out of earmark reserves which um
it'd be nice to know what those
earmarked reserves
were before you took them out of the out
of the budget
um and is it not possible i know you
can't use
borrowing to um to go to
uh revenue but is it not possible to
take more earmarked reserves out and
borrow more so that
the the gap is no longer
the hole that you've got is no longer
there i think i've tried to explain it
correctly but it just seems you're
borrowing money obviously i can
understand that money's cheap at the
moment
um wouldn't it have been better to
borrow a little bit more
take a bit more out of retirement
reserves and borrow a little bit more
and so as not to have this this gap that
you've got
coming up next year thank you
yeah so the um the capital grants will
include
um any grants that we've got relating to
schemes in 2122
so you can relate them back to the um
capital programme appendix in the papers
as well
because they've got um items identified
as to where the funds come from in
brackets
so if the future high streets fund will
be included in there
um in terms of the earmark reserves i'll
come to borrowing but in a minute in
terms of the emark reserves
um so what we've done with that is we
had some carry forward reserves
and the vast majority of the monies that
we're using
um we always knew prior to covid
that there was going to be a funding
issue um because of
government changing the rules on new
homes bonus changing the rules on
business rates and we're losing the
growth that we've
um obtained over the last few years um
so in anticipation of that
over the last few years we've been
putting money aside
to um alleviate that cliff fall that was
meant to have been this year obviously
covert came along and messed all that up
um we've benefited by that because
obviously that growth wasn't taken away
could be taken away next year now
depending on what happens with
government consultation on the whole
funding package
so we were able to use that funding this
year to bridge the gap that kovid had
produced you know over and above what
government haven't funded us for
so that sort of pushes the the issue on
a little bit which is why we've now got
the 1.2 million gap next year because
our medium term financial plan assumes
that we'll lose that growth next year
the borrowing that you talk about is
borrowing for the specific projects that
are
within the capital program so all our
business cases in the future
are around borrowing because our capital
receipts are dwindling
um if we've got specific capital
receipts for specific projects where we
use them for that
um but outside of that um so like hotel
development
you know that's where the borrowing is
um but again it's based on
a business case so as long as the
business case stacks up
with the borrowing in there and we make
a return then that's where the borrowing
is coming from
so the borrowing is only based on the
capital
programme projects that are in there for
next year that require borrowing
increasing borrowing doesn't um
protect your budget gap or or change
what you're doing with earmarked
reserves because
um that's not a source of funding that
will reduce that gap
it's only a a funding source where
you've got then to
put money aside to repay capital or
repay
the interest on the borrowing so
that's that's where we are with
borrowing it can only be used
to fund pacific capital projects
does that answer your questions
yeah thank you very much thank you uh
councillor adrian patch please
thank you chair um i just wanted to
raise an issue which has come up
at council uh within the last 12 months
and that is the possibility of bringing
some kind of wallet initially i think it
was talked about a voluntary
charge for um tourists for um
for occupying hotel beds and maybe other
accommodation for tourists as well
i just wondered if any modeling has been
done
sort of financially to see what sort of
income
we might be expected to achieve under
different scenarios for instance if as
some have suggested there were a
compulsory tourist tax
on hotel beds across um team bridge
it would seem that we've got a situation
now where there's likely to be huge
demand for holidaying
in devon and well across team bridge um
this forthcoming summer and
indeed probably sort of future summers
for the foreseeable time
and this this might be quite a
substantial opportunity depending on how
on
how such a scheme were administered and
what levels charges were set
um as sort of some kind of tourist tax
and i know that's a contentious term
but initially the question is simply has
any modeling been undertaken as to what
um this type of exercise might bring in
yeah thanks for the question yeah um it
was talked about as you say
um a while ago but i haven't been
involved in any modelling
i think there's some legal aspects
around how you could bring the charge in
as well
so i think that was being looked at but
i'll certainly follow it up and
and see where where that might take us
in the future because it'd be one
of interest to me as well to see if that
comes in i mean
essentially it can be deemed a separate
tax charge can't it but
it might be of use if we've got a
significant income
or in uh input from
people coming on holiday here in the
next couple of years because i've
covered so
yeah i will look into that thank you
thank you
[Music]
i've got an executive member but it
doesn't say who with their hand up
um
it's nina jefferies hi nina hi
it was justin i can't see very well
because my screen's so tiny but it was
just um
in response to councillor patch
and there's been several presentations
on the tourism contribution
that uh i'm planning to bring in this
year if that's what you were referring
to and we have done some modeling
obviously the accommodation providers
have been greatly affected
with um the covid and lockdowns and
everything
um but there are plans for us to look at
launching that this year
um we're just going to be going through
some modelling from march
to have a look at um the potential
changes with the movements and people
coming down here to stay
etcetera so we can definitely update you
on those figures at some point
in the future thank you
thank you nina um i think that's all the
questions now
uh right if i read out the
recommendation um
that the committee recommends that the
proposals be considered together with
any subsequent consultation comments
or approval by council as the final
budget
2021-22 and the outline plan for
subsequent years 2022
23 and 2020 23
24. the proposed budget includes
an increase in council tax of five
pounds or 2.85
to 180 pounds 17 continued funding for
climate change officer and enhanced
planning enforcement
increased provision in the capital
program for climate change projects the
continuing reduction in new homes bonus
other central funding reductions in
particular provisional
assumptions or business rates for future
years and reset the baseline
reserves at 30 the net revenue budget or
just under 2
million increased support for housing
including the team bridge 100 whilst
backing business
and bringing people and organizations
together for local
neighbourhood planning infrastructure
delivery plan
investment funded by community
infrastructure levy and
external sources were available
continuation of grant funded southwest
regional monitoring program
town centre investment in infrastructure
and employment
use of long-term borrowing where
appropriate
assumptions of a 1.5 pay deal
reducing rural funding frozen during the
covet 19 pandemic
would like to propose that we recommend
that
um could i have a second on that please
i'll second that chair thank you i think
that probably be a roll call for that
one
yes chair we can do a roll call for this
one
okay lovely thank you all right
councillor clarence
i think he's left he's gone okay
councillor david cox
in favor councillor foden
yes councillor hawking
yeah four councillor malone
sorry four councillor natalie
or councillor patch
or councillor rolison
or councillor thorne
or councillor jenks
and your self-chair
that's unanimous okay okay um
i think we're coming up to an hour and a
half um
chair sorry if i may just we just need
to do the other part
of the recommendation um to council to
note the mid-year review of treasury
management
appendix eight which is agenda pages
71-74
okay um okay i'll note that
um i think everyone can do a hands on
that just to make sure everyone's happy
to note that
are there any against
and any obs uh
councillor cox david cox are you voting
against
no in favor no okay and
although it says none against are there
any abstentions
that's fine that's unanimous thank you
chair okay
um i think maybe have a quick break now
because we're coming up to an hour and a
half
um that be okay with everyone
if we said 10 minutes is that okay
what's happening
sorry trish i couldn't hear you there
all right
10 minutes
you
[Music]
could we get started again now please
sounds like a good idea
right
do we need to do another roll call are
we okay with
um i think trish isn't back
yet okay i'm trying to give it another
oh
sorry
anyone isn't here can they put their
hand up that's a good way of doing it
um do we need to roll call again trish
or
is everyone there yes chair that would
that would be best
okay do that then yeah okay
okay um councillor david cox i'm here
councillor foden
president cancer hawking
yeah i'm here but may have to leave just
after 12 i'm sorry
councillor malone
council malone are you with us
at the moment okay counselor nutley
president
councillor patch president councillor
rollerson
president cancer thorne president
councillor jenks
present yourself chair just checking
counselor malone are you
back with us
no we're all here we're all present
chair apart from counselor malone
okay thank you um
item 10 council strategy performance
monitoring
q3 um i'd like to ask
executive member council connet and liz
jingwell
project manager business improvement
development to present the report
the ebbs will then be invited to make
any additional comments
on their areas of responsibility council
account list can ask you to present to
the report
thank you thank you very much just
briefly introduce
and then hand over to liz to take
colleagues through the detail so very
much a summarized format and you'll see
the performance of the council
and the highlight of the areas where
performance
is less than green um very much
i think a good performance for the
council given the
past year and the challenges that all of
us particularly all of our staff have
faced
so with that chair i'll pass over to liz
thank you very much
oh thank you councillor connect so this
is the
quarter three performance reports those
covers appeared from the 1st of october
to the 31st of december
during which about which we have the
second lockdown in place
for four weeks the report
then goes on to give a brief summary of
the finance which
you've already heard of detailed uh
information from our finance officer
previous in the previous item in terms
of the actual t10 programmes
this is the same as it was the last
couple of quarters we've got seven of
the
t10 programs are currently on track
across the whole council strategy for
both
both ons committees we've got the roof
over our heads continues to be a concern
within
os committee one going to town out about
an
active continuing to be concerns in ons
committee 2. of the performance
indicators this time we have
38 in in the strategy included of which
we've got 11 ahead of target 9 on target
and 4
under and those four underperforming
ones are within the roof over
over our head to them program and
they're covered later on in the report
in more detail now this is actually an
improvement
on the previous quarter when there were
more underperforming pis
the t10 projects we've got 54 reported
of which 47
are on track and seven are reported with
a concerned status
of those we've got four
reported in roof over our heads and the
other
ones are reported within the other ons
ii committee
report okay
if we move on to page 79 this gives us
more detail about the uh
the areas within the ons one committee
so
starting at the top we've got action on
climate t10
this is on track however we can see that
there's uh
one project in here that is i've been
that
assessed as a caution the review of the
use of single plastics within our
council offices
this has obviously been delayed or put
on the whole because
actually not many of us are visiting our
offices for work at the moment
but there are plans afoot to increase
that and
run out initiatives once we do start
returning to to work in our office areas
roof over our heads this the whole
program still remains the caution status
and as you'll see in the actual summary
report uh the reason for this
is that the direct result of covid
national lock downs and obviously the
housing
delivery chain however there is some
good news within this overview as well
as
the areas which haven't managed to
progress due to housing delivery etc
we still managed to have a good number
of good reduction in
empty homes and preventing homelessness
performance indicators are still
performing ahead of target
which is good news in terms of the ones
that aren't performing so well we've got
net additional homes provided
this this has been impacted as you can
see across the table bar
throughout the um kobe pandemic
this we're not going to meet target this
year that's stated in
the notes here and there's also some
information regarding
the new local plan review and the new
local plan process which has been put
into place together with the
note about the increased targets that
we're trying to achieve on housing
similarly the pis
down here there's two unaffordable homes
there's one on
average uh homes affordable homes urban
areas and
in rural areas again these have had a
significant hit due to covered
restrictions and slow down in the
housing house building
however and neither of these are likely
to meet target but there is some
progress being made with the
affordable homes in urban areas which
again is cited in the notes here
the final one is to do with vulnerable
nerve new residents being assisted to
stay in their own homes
and this one does look like it will be
on target by the end of the year despite
the curvature restrictions that we've
had in place which is again
going to be good news so the
the final three caution areas within
this report
are the three projects under roof over
our head
developing social rental departments 10
units of supported accommodation
and the plan for shared housing scheme
for single househeads
again these leads have all been impacted
due to the copic restrictions and the
pandemic
uh the impact directly or more well
directly on budget and on the housing
chain
delivery
the final two areas within this report
are clean scene
where it's currently on track there's a
note here to say that we're still
waiting for final data for the household
recycling rate
and residual household waste
that will be coming out very very
shortly by the end of this month
and then also strong communities is also
on track
as a programme thank you
thank you thank you very much liz um
are there any committee members got any
questions on that please
uh councillor dave rollerson
thank you chairman um first of all
i i think the team are doing a great job
because it can't be easy
in these very very difficult times to
achieve any target so
that's great i'm just wondering that
we're hearing
on the news and so on that kovid may be
with us for quite a long time in one
shape or another
even with the vaccines and is there
anything we can do to compensate
uh for the impact on covid impact kobit
has on our activities
so that we can reach targets in the
longer term i mean if our ways of
working and
and our precautions need to go forward
maybe not quite as severe as they are
but in some sense we're gonna have to
find a way around this aren't we
and i don't think this is a quick
solution but is is there something you
can do in the medium to long term
just in case kovitz is going to be with
us for a while
thank you chairman
uh in the sense that there are some
things that we we can do
so i'm very heartened by the way the
council
uh have continued challenging empty
homes and reduced that
and have done work to make sure the
disabled facility grants are out
we're doing those homes adaptations so
what we can
where we can how we can being inventive
and adaptive i think is
you know what we all want there are some
things over which we
can have little control so the rate at
which developers build our houses
which affects us because we're held to
account for it but we don't build
the houses that developers have consent
for um
i think uh nationally there's going to
have to be a conversation around that
in terms of how the nation builds houses
i mean just
the widest general point around that and
i think that's a governmental
conversation with
with the industry um within cambridge uh
certainly when i speak with the chief
officers and i believe executive members
do as well we are very focused on
getting done that which we can do and if
we can't do it understanding the reasons
for it
and keeping it under review so i hope
that provides some reassurance to
colleagues
that we're very mindful of getting on
with things
that we can get on with and trying to
find ways around so that people aren't
necessarily kept waiting although in
truth over the year
some people haven't experienced a delay
because we've not been able to do things
as quickly as we would have liked
thank you for that um thank you chair
thank you for the answer ellen
okay i think nina's still got her
hand up on him
i've got no more questions on that just
uh if any members of the executive got
any comments they'd like to add to the
section i
don't think so thank you all for that um
[Music]
right onto item 10 executive
member biannual presentation councillor
jackie
sorry chair if i may um
yeah there's a recommendation with
the um with a gender item 10 on the
performance monitoring
um to note the report and actions being
taken to rectified performance
issues detailed in the appendix so we
just need to have a
proposal and secondary on that please
i'd like to propose to note that
happy to say okay can we do a hands on
that one please
and thank you are there any against
and any abstentions there's one
abstention
it was carried by a majority thank you
chair thank you
item 10 executive member by annual
presentation councillor jackie hook
climate change
there will be time for questions
following the update
should questions be asked the council
that does not have the information at
hand to answer
responses will be provided by email or
via the members
newsletter uh councilhook could ask you
to give your update to the committee
thank you very much
okay thank you chair um there should be
some science coming up now okay thank
you very much
um i was gonna divide my um presentation
into
two um sections so firstly um
climate change and within climate change
i will
include work we're doing on the
ecological emergency
and secondly work in the area of flood
and coastal risk
management so next slide please
um most of you will know
hopefully that we appointed william
elliot as our climate change officer
early in
2020 next slide
um and allocating the necessary staff
resource was a commitment we made within
our climate change declaration
which we made back in april 2019
this photo was taken february last year
obviously pre-covered because there's
william and i shaking hands um
we have an ambitious net zero target as
as we all know of 2025 and this is the
district-wide target not just a target
for the
own council's operations william
works within the environmental health
team
led by david eaton but as you might
imagine his work is cross cutting across
all the departments of the council i
just wanted to take this opportunity to
thank david and william for
the tremendous work they're putting in
and the progress we've made
um which obviously i'll go on now to
outline
but i also wanted to thank the officers
and the senior leadership team at
um the council and the commitment
of all of our councillors um to the
target that we have
um there's a unanimity of purpose at
team bridge
which not all councils experience
we are all on the same page and you know
i wanted to thank everybody for that
we also have the fantastic and
invaluable support of
our community partners action on climate
in team bridge
who we meet with regularly um they have
a role in
helping to take project forward and
coordinating action
out in our community and i hope you're
all familiar with their work because i
do always mention it every time i talk
about climate change
um just to say i have attended and
spoken at several
webinar and virtual events um across
devon
and nationwide actually and um
can report that many councils and other
district councillors
are envious of the progress we are
making and the level
of collaboration we have achieved at
this council
not that we're resting on our laurels at
all but you know i just wanted to report
that because
you know members might not be aware of
that um it's only when you go out and
talk to other people you realize
that the good position that we're in um
next um side please
um so there's two um
yeah just talking about our district's
carbon footprint now
um there's obviously two elements um the
district's
carbon footprint and the council's own
carbon footprint so first to look at the
district's wider footprint
the impact of newly built development
does actually form
a small part of the district's total
emissions and new building stock
in fact only forms one percent of the
emissions of all
total housing stock but of course we do
have the means to strongly influence new
development and building design
by our local plan so a couple of sides
on the local plan the first
one obviously about our existing local
plan which provides the current context
for
managing planning applications um many
including myself don't feel that the
policies within our current plan
um are reflect the level of carbon
reduction that we are required
to achieve but we are legally bound by
this local plan at the moment
and you know as i've reported before we
have updated
um the carbon calculator which sits
behind policy s7
um so that now it's based entirely on
building emissions
and excludes other factors such as the
provision of
sustainable travel infrastructure which
had resulted
in in a slightly absurd situation where
some developments
merely passed policy s7 by being located
near to a bus route or cycle route for
example
without having to look at their building
emissions at all
so that has now changed but of course
all of those other aspects easy charging
sustainable travel etc are still covered
by other policies within the local plan
um so this new carbon calculator is
providing a significant challenge to new
development now
and increasing the level of carbon
reduction required and we were able to
do that because it was updating the
local plan
in line with national carbon reduction
targets
it's not something that you can do to
update all policies but
you can update them to bring them in
line with national targets which is what
we did
next slide please so on to
um our new draft local plan which
includes a whole chapter on climate
change
and these as you know were worked up by
the local planned working group meetings
cross-party
meetings public consultation on the
policy aspects
of the draft local plan took place
between march and july
last year so there's some way to go
before this plan is adopted
but obviously we'd like to progress as
quickly as possible
um so that we can get these ambitious
policies that relate to
biodiversity sustainable travel net zero
homes etcetera and you know we'll
provide an important tool going forward
and foundation for a sustainable and
resilient recovery for our district
obviously within the context of national
demands and national
planning policy but this is something um
that we would like to
um uh progress with as quickly as
possible and i hope others agree
next slightly so district heating
network
um hopefully you'll know a bit about
this it's obviously a very complex
um project involves the coordination of
several housing developments um
the county exeter city because there's a
school involved as well
heat network providers etc and requires
the installation of
an underground network which happens
prior to the
development with the heat being sourced
by the waste to energy plant at mapford
which will be pumped through to homes
and avoids the houses having to connect
to the gas
grid um the t rig project lead is
fergus pate but as mentioned this is a
very complex project
which requires the cooperation of a
number of partners including a number of
housing developers but success here will
result in a significant
approximate 70 carbon saving from this
development going forwards
and will act as an exemplar for other
such schemes
um but and we should remember of course
that it is the um
the biggest part of the carbon footprint
of development is the ongoing um
use by residents of heating and how they
travel about in their daily lives
this is where the major significant
impact of new development will be
and if we can get the results right
through good planning now
then that's a significant role that our
council can play
in terms of the new development that we
will have
taking place in our district next slide
please
so electric vehicle charging obviously
reducing car use is the key objective
going forwards but
in a largely rural district the car will
be here to stay
and will increasingly be low emission
and or electric
and councils do obviously have a role in
kickstarting charging and provision
so we have approved our electric vehicle
and low emission vehicles policy which
can be found on our website
and this connects us amongst other
things to making new residential and
larger
employment developments ev ready in
recognition that most
ev charging of course will take place
either at home
or at work and our current and
draft local plan also contain policies
that will
require new development to install ev
charging
um but we will be installing public
charging and we already have the four
that we've installed
at buck fosley and chubbily and there
are others to follow so there's the
davitti project
um which uh they're due to be installed
by february next year
and um there's four locations barton
hill car park
um east cliff car park timmouth new
founding way newton abbott and fourth
house
newton avenue and then another uh
project
um the off street uh residential
charging scheme
which um in our case actually will be
sites that
are in car parks um i won't
read out the actual names of the
cardboard but just to let you know
those sites are in newton now but king
stink and buck fossey chudley
bobby tracy morton hamster sheldon
dawlish timbers ashburton
star cross whitaker and doris warren so
across our
whole district and that's another bid
we've put in and
involved with but it's worth remembering
that um
homeowners and small businesses with
their own charging facility are now
now able to rent out their driveway or
premises to other ev users
and you can find out where they are via
zap map and co-charger and
other such um facilities worth
mentioning also that we are currently in
talks with co-cars about expanding their
network of shared electric cars and
shared charge
points into teambridge so the
opportunities for shared and public
charging are growing rapidly obviously
and will continue to do so
and we will we are picking that up along
the way
next slide please so just a couple of
slides on housing initiatives obviously
this is martin wrigley's area
but timbres district council is
continually looking at opportunities to
take advantage of government funding
for delivering energy efficiency and low
carbon heating measures
to our existing housing stock and that's
where
our 23 of our district carbon emissions
come from
existing housing stock we've recently
received confirmation that we've been
successful in a bid
for 1.14 million pounds
green homes grant and that will deliver
air source heat pumps and associated
energy works
last year also we launched a solar bulk
buying project
the solar together devon which enables
those taking part to achieve
substantial savings on the purchase of
residential solar and battery storage
the update was really good and the works
are currently underway at those
properties
next slide you also know of course of
our desire to build our own
council social rent affordable
properties which are also
low carbon so we have drake street drake
road east street and sherbourne house in
utah
which is the first of a pipeline of such
projects
um so not only are these um properties
at social rent levels but of course i'll
be cheaper to heat
and run for the tenants next slide
now going on to look at the council's
own carbon footprint
and this is where william has been
concentrating most of his time since he
joined us
on the basis of course that we can't
tell others what to do
until we've laid out a clear plan of how
we will deal with our own emissions
so a key first action is measuring where
we are and then monitoring our
improvement
william has completed our 2018 carbon
footprint
which is no simple exercise especially
considering our scope 3 emissions those
over which we don't have direct
influence and
form actually the largest portion of our
emissions
he's now working on our 29 19 2020
footprint
and also working on the carbon action
plan to identify the most
cost and carbon efficient ways to
becoming a carbon neutral council
next time so the carbon action pram
plan will outline about 40 projects
which cover our 15
top carbon emitting buildings we've
allocated
3.6 million over the next three years
but i've also put in grant applications
to the public sector decarbonization
scheme to provide 3.1 million
which if we were successful will enable
us to keep complete even more of those
top projects with the allocated 3.6
million
we were due to hear um whether we were
successful with the public sector
decarbonisation bid
last week we haven't heard yet but the
communication with funders
goes on and we remain hopeful of success
so
i'll let you have the news when when we
hear it
um next slide please
so you'll all be aware of the context
above us
and devon's own carbon plan
um as you know cambridge district
council is a signatory of the devon
climate emergency declaration the
interim
devon carbon plan is currently out for
public constant consultation
and you are able to make comments up
until february the 15th so i
urge you to do that the citizens
assembly
which if it was not for kobe would have
taken place by now
is planning to take place this year
probably in a virtual format
and we'll consider the more potentially
controversial aspects
of the plan the final devon carbon plan
is due for adoption this summer
um just to say it is a non-statutory
plan and does of course depend on all
partners including ourselves
enacting its policies and actions next
slide
onto just a couple of slides on um the
ecology work
as a result of our declaration of an
ecological emergency september last year
um as i've said before i i summarized
the work
at that last ons committee um you know
there is much good work
going on already at our council and
together with partners
and uh they're always sort of being
hidden away in a sense and didn't neatly
fall under
any executive members responsibilities
so
you know hopefully we will be high
profiling it a lot more now
um there is no dedicated officer to this
emergency
and this work doesn't fall under
williams job description
um in terms of work um
as you know we had our 1500 per year
target on
tree planting and we have kept to that
target
the tree strategy is nearing completion
and will soon be available for
public consultation the council is given
five thousand pounds to devon wildlife
trust
to support habitat mapping and
monitoring habitat quality and obviously
this will inform decision making about
the interventions needed
um and how we can um get net
biodiversity gain
next slide please um
hopefully you're aware of the current
consultation on the connecting to nature
project which runs until
february 15th that covers the heart of
team bridge area
newton have at king state and king's
care as well and he's looking at linking
public green spaces and improving their
value to wildlife
as well as access to for the public
so in terms of what we as a council can
do um
to increase our activity on the
ecological um emergency agenda
um you will be discussing as the next
gender item
um uh discussing setting up a possible
task group
but hopefully we'll look at how we can
support environmental
organizations that are already working
in our district
to achieve more through better linkages
and investigate funding
sources and how we might maximize their
use in teambridge uh i for one um
continually seen on my facebook
feed um opportunities for funding for
environmental projects
and is about bringing all those together
and
picking up that opportunity one of those
environment
organizations that is already doing a
great job is action on climate in team
bridge ecology group
which as you'll know have set up the
wildlife wardens scheme
the wardens are volunteers they can
operate flexibly in their parish or
chosen area
and look after and improve wildlife and
habitats
training is provided and no expert
knowledge is required
so i hope you'll to continue to promote
that
they've had tremendous success already i
think over 70
and several of those already trained up
so you know they're doing really well
but there is room for more
next slide thank you right on to
um the second portion of
my presentation and this is on flood and
coastal risk
management this work is led by richard
rainbow who's our drainage and coastal
manager
next site kimber district council has
statutory responsibilities as a risk
management authority
tasked with managing flood risk within
our district which includes managing the
flood defense assets
water courses and land which is under
our control
cambridge district council also acts as
the coastal protection authority
managing coastal erosion and flood
defense assets under our control
staff also provide planning advice
related to strategic planning so
local plan and individual development
projects
um so planning applications
and obviously our local planners and
sites etc next slide thank you
so team bridge hosts the teen estuary
and coastal partnership
which brings together a variety of
stakeholders and interest groups
to ensure coordinated approach to
coastal management
economic development public access and
water quality
the partnership leads or is involved in
a number of initiatives covering these
areas of work
and also operates a small grants fund
for community groups wanting to help
manage the partnership area cambridge
district council also hosts the south
devon and dorset coastal authorities
group
and this group delivers the shoreline
management plans
which informs strategic planning related
to the coast
and agrees coastal protection schemes
thank you
on to the southwest coastal monitoring
program
um and this is the largest area in the
national coast
monitoring and programme so it's a
national program
the program provides a cost-effective
standardized method of monitoring the
coastal environment
the information is used for the
development of shoreline management
plans
coastal defense strategy and flood
defence
this is all funded by defra and um
the data collected is available free of
charge to anyone
so the website's there um you can go and
have a look at the data that's collected
yourselves which is really interesting
okay
next slide onto the local flood risk
management strategy
this is devon county council strategy
and is due for approval in spring this
year
following recent public consultation and
the good news is that several areas in
our district have been
prioritized for flood alleviation works
in
dulish timmouth newton albert kingston
and exeter in addition work
on other related projects for example as
part of the garden communities funding
is supporting the strategy including
more
innovative approaches to natural flood
risk management
in river catchments designed to keep
water retained
naturally and draining more gradually to
the river system
um and a lot of that work will be
related to the development in the newton
area and funded by the garden garden
communities
project so that's some really
interesting work on
natural flood risk management um i i
should say there's a lot of detail
behind these slides and i am rushing
through it in a sense so you know do ask
any questions
afterwards because there's a lot more
that i could say
next slide please
a few slides on the district's flood
risk management responsibilities
so um flood risk management has an
important role in strategic planning as
i said
and there are two relevant policies on
our local plan
s6 which covers the need for new
development proposals to take account
of likely chain climate change impacts
such as increased
flood risk temperature and wind changes
and then policy en4
which seeks to direct development to
lower risk areas
and controls the type of development and
adaptation measures required in higher
risk
areas obviously the illustrations there
show
um newton abbott with um much
many of our local plan sites in newton
avenue and the regeneration of the town
centre
bradley lane etc and obviously
where it's situated in the flood zone is
will impact on options and design
but also enable um improvements to be
made
as well so opportunities as well as
risks
okay next slide
teamwork district council has a number
of drainage and flood risk assets of its
own which need to be maintained
um examples like oakworld dam and the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] valley um down in timmuth
recent larger projects have been the
drainage improvements at bakers park
related to the pavilion which is the top
right picture there
the top left picture is at macford's
there were works that were taking
place at macford sangs
um the bottom left picture is of down
and the bottom right is decoy park
um and team bridge also
provides an uh services to southam's
district council
providing them advice in relation to
planning applications
for which we receive an income from them
okay thank you um
the council obviously has a role also in
responding to flood and storm events the
last major one was
storm dennis um february last year
um just some information and stats there
on the council's response um
so as well as the immediate response
there there is then the repair and
damage um to assets and the
and the response to repairing those you
know is over many years
and still some work to go um you'll know
of the over topping of
whole being down as well but um
that did its job basically um and
slowed down the flow of water which is
exactly what it's supposed to do
and obviously the garden community's
money will be looking at that whole
catchment
the lemon and team to see how
we manage future flood risk towards
newton ava
next slide shoreline
management plan so this flow diagram
shows how the plan fits in with the
national planning for flooding and more
local engineering and
planning strategies the strategy is
carried out by the south devon and
dorset coastal group
um which cambridge district hosts the
plan has just been
refreshed which is just a sort of health
check of of the policies
um okay thank you
coastal management so external funds
have been obtained to
fund the production of a timmoth and
holcomb beach management plan
and this will provide the evidence base
for flood and coastal capital schemes
and importantly assess the impacts and
interactions
with programmed and ongoing operations
of
work such as the network rail resilience
program
team bridge um oh sorry next slide
yeah just on to um the x-men marina
dredging which obviously is a current
and controversial topic
team bridge has challenged and continues
to challenge the license that the marine
management organization have awarded to
eczema marina to dispose of their
dredged material
the new license was awarded following
the suspension of their original license
for disposal
which was nearer to the shore and
resulted in black sludge
washing ashore the new site seven
kilometers offshore
um is still controversial um
and we've had several uh written and
verbal communications with the mmo
inc and include an rmp graham smith who
is our
coastal officer and i have and other
affected stakeholders have met twice
with the marine management
organization to voice our concerns
um those concerns are particularly
relate to the
inadequate sampling of the dredge
material
and inadequate modeling of the impacts
of the current disposal
site other organizations um
for example extra university have now
offered to do further modelling
and the mmo have confirmed that they
will take on board the results of any
additional modern modelling so just to
say this is ongoing we have um
submitted a complaint we've had a
response to that complaint and
since then we've met twice with them
with other stakeholders
so this is ongoing and i hope
the mmo will take account of any further
modelling that is done
on on the disposal at the new site okay
thank you
network rail southwest resilience
project which
obviously has various different
components to it which are listed there
hopefully most of you are familiar with
this but obviously this is resilience
for a major sustainable transport route
not only of highly relevance to our
district but also carrying on into the
rest of devon
and cornwall the marine parade and boat
cove sections are nearing completion
the more northern dawlish section which
includes work on the sea wall and
doorless station itself
is underway at the moment i think we all
know that
um the timotheum section which you'll be
aware went through a process of
extensive public consultation
is um the responses are now being
considered by network braille
with residual revising revisions to the
scheme design
expected um then the remaining section
is the tunnels and cliffs section
between delish and holcomb
and a prior approval application is
expected for that
section soon thank you
back to the southwest coastal monitoring
program this
um infographic really is just outlining
um some statistics relating to the
successes of the program
this year so um for example just picking
out some
there were 267 topographic surveys
undertaken
with 13 wave boys which operate 24
7 and support 27 different local
authorities and the environment
agency with incident response and scheme
development
but that's a very important um
monitoring program okay thank you
um this is the last slide um just
looking at some of the
budget and funding opportunities so
these are bids that we put in or other
funding
that will need to be found eg for
maintenance of pumping stations etcetera
um so just this january um
we put in a bid to the um environment
agency innovation resilience fund
that includes projects um for example at
cumintined for natural flood risk
management
and a newton abbott strategic flood risk
assessment
which is looking at wider aspects of
flood risk management
um also looking at natural processes so
that's what i mentioned before the lemon
and the team looking at how natural
processes could can be used
also a coastal bid for a new education
visitor
and coastal management center at dallas
warren nature reserve
there's a whole list here of um funding
bids we've put in
also for timoth um
converted down king stanton a a long
list here of
um funding opportunities and bids we've
put in
um okay thank you i i think that's it i
mean there's a lot more information that
i have here but
i'm conscious of time and um perhaps if
people
you know particularly want to know a bit
more about anything
they can ask a question on it thank you
thank you very much jackie for that um
let's see we've got a need uh i've got
my [ __ ] in please
uh yeah thank you uh chairman um
very interesting thank you for the
presentation i'm very interested
as any nickname uh town councillor would
be
and in fact any newton now that resident
would be it's a whole beam damn
um i've been asking for quite some time
over the last few years
about the um about
actually upgrading that dam um it's
it's obviously when it was built and
you're quite right it has done a
wonderful job
um but it i believe it has come to the
stage now where it needs to be upgraded
it is as you said it has been
it has been over topped um so that must
be a warning to us
to actually either hire the dam or to
try and do something
a bit further upstream to try and cut
cut down the flow that's coming down the
river
um i noticed from the dam
down from the dam down towards the town
center certainly through bradley woods
and bradley
meadows and that a lot of the trees
which have come down in the river
they've just been left
uh i've asked the question i've never
really got a full answer back
from it is this being done intentionally
and by the environment agency to
actually slow the water flow down and
allow it to flood the
flood the metals that's um bradley
meadows or not
um i think if at all
uh jackie whether it be at all possible
uh i think the actual 10 council would
benefit from an update on
on what is happening this is an
important flood prevention
um issue for
newton abbott and i think um the more we
can
know about this and the more we can do
about the whole mean down the better
and it does worry us that there is
obviously a lot of
a lot of development going on around
around that area above the above the
homemade diamond i'm talking about
hill park um barton etc
and all this water i appreciate there's
been this
um catchment areas and that being set up
etcetera etcetera within the development
but all this water eventually will find
its way down into the lemon
and the lemon is the main river that
runs through
through nicknavit the team is on the
experts but the
actual lemon run through it so um for me
i am very concerned about the fact that
home being damn over
topped and i would like um to be assured
that everything
possible is being done to make sure that
dam is is
suitable for the next hundred years
thank you
did you want me to answer uh jackie if
you could jeff that'd be great
okay i mean obviously um we all share
the concern
but um yeah so there's a couple of
funded studies at the moment looking
into the river lemon and team catch i'll
ask
richard to comment but um yeah as i say
the whole
holding down that is his job and it's
it's performed well
and as well as that sort of conventional
flood
um management tool of a dam
there there are these other um options
that are being looked at as well
but maybe um richards if you'd like to
comment
yes so it's a whole big damn so like any
damn they're designed to overflow so
there's there's been lots of studies
been
um undertaken and there's recent modern
studies he's been undertaking newt now
it's look at the performance of holding
down how it operates um and currently it
shows it is
it is working and does provide the level
of protection required to newton abbott
so whole boom down was designed to
restrict flows coming through the town
centre
and and the recent modeling activity
looks at how
how the system operates and there's a
better understanding of how the walls
and culverts that operate through the
town center so
whole being dam you know its performance
is there the dams are designed to over
top so
that over topping the dam it is designed
to over top
so it was designed to restrict flow to a
certain um
quantity through the town centre so that
that did that in february
um and then showed the defenses there
was still capacity left in the defenses
through
the town centre so so whole beam in
itself is is
is is working at this design standard
and there's work on going at the moment
to look
at how um sort of resilience in terms of
climate change and future changes in the
catchment um can be done
particularly upstream of whole beam dam
so how those developments
you know parcels coming forward how
their surface water is dealt with
um obviously those sort of hill park
areas do drain to whole being dams so
currently those areas have been
classified as critical drainage area to
manage those sort of surface water
inputs into the lemon
and so there's there is lots of studies
going on at the moment the
sfra we're proposing for the garden
communities will support that work to
see
how um see what's the art of the
possible
currently the defenses in newton abbott
are shown to be performing
um and and we we gave presentations to
the town council prior to covid on that
sort of work
um and a degree yet we would definitely
come back to town council there to give
an update on sort of whole beam
and and particularly give you an update
on how that performance is
um and how how it responded during that
winter period
um regarding the trees left in the
lemons so
uh that's there's there's sort of a
double-sided to trees left in
left in the lemons so trees are normally
removed where they are causing a flood
risk
issue to property so at bakers park
where trees are
landed against the tree catcher there
they're actively removed or where trees
are tangled up in infrastructure such as
pipe crossings across the lemon
upstream of baker's park where they fall
down into the woods
actually they provide benefit in terms
of
you know directing flows back into the
floodplain so where
where areas there the you know woody
debris within the watercourse can
actually
establish storage within the floodplain
which might not necessarily get
activated during flood conditions so
it is a toss-up between where it's
necessary in terms of flood risk but
where we can leave them in they do
actually provide a flood risk benefit
and also an ecological benefit to the
channel
particularly where you've got habitats
around you know having
pools of water for fisheries and
different types of habitats so
they are they are removed where they
cause a flood risk issue but where
they're not actually causing an
issue and where they actually cause
they're actually a benefit to flood risk
they're generally left in the channel
yeah thank you for that um mr chairman i
am going to leave the meeting now but
thank you for that explanation and look
forward to an update at 10 council in
some
future day thank you thank you um
councillor david cox please
thanks very much thank you very much
indeed i'm really pleased with that
that we're taking the dumping of the ex
marina sludge
seriously involving next university we
do need robust testing
and we need someone with credibility
doing that testing so i'm really pleased
that that's happening and uh
i certainly congratulate uh council her
god knows when she
has time to breathe with all the things
she's initiative she's doing um
most most welcome so um if we but if we
could have a little bit more about
what's going on with the
dumping that would be helpful to share
with tim tim of residents about that
because it is a great concern it's also
of course great concern to torbay
borough council as well so i do thank
her for that and
graham smith for the work they're doing
on that and if we have a bit more
information that would be fantastic
yeah that's fine i'll put an update
together
yeah hey thank you
um councillor john nutley please
thank you chair and uh thank you jackie
for a very excellent presentation
um and i'm pleased obviously that
electric charging points has been
mentioned because i know
on our car parking review group we've
been
discussing this and obviously looking
for costings
of uh for installation of these and also
what the revenue could be got from them
i know you can actually lease these um
in
in various from various firms um so
i mean as i say excellent news on that
um
obviously on on friday last friday
um dartmouth national park and alex
gandy um we actually had a discussion
you may well
be aware of this i don't know um on
actually the
carbon uh admissions etc and the carbon
devin carlin plan um where the authority
um
you know its ambition is to become
carbon neutral
in its operation by 2025. um
the other thing also that the um
achieving the uh
zero devon plan the draft carbon plan
carbon plan set out a road map for devon
to achieve net zero carbon by 2050
at the latest with the interim target of
50
reduction by 2030 below uh 2010
levels uh the reason for this timetable
is that
reducing emissions is not something that
can be achieved in local
um was it um as i say i don't know
whether
william do at all uh you know
liaise with with uh alex at all and have
any correspondence that way
um which you know working across parties
and authorities i think is a is an
excellent idea
um but yeah i mean to say more than
welcome for this report and
presentation and could the actual slides
be forwarded to council so we could uh
look at our you know pass them on to our
um groups and that uh obviously you
weren't well aware of the
ace in ashburton um but obviously for
other uh
councils and parish councils as well so
that'd be good if you could do that
please
i can't imagine that's a problem and
there are as i say a whole set of
detailed notes behind those sites as
well and that and i should think
we can um let members have those as well
um just to say on the devon carbon plan
obviously
they are seeking for views on the target
they've currently set of 2050 so they
are seeking views
um my views would set would be i'm sure
similar to others that it needs to be
a lot sooner than that our district has
a target of 2025 and most of the
districts have a target of 2030.
so you know please do put those comments
in
thank you uh councillor chris jenks
please
yeah hi jackie and thank you for that
that was that was that was really
informative
it's it's nice to see there's so much
going on um but with all
that's that's that's going on i'm i'm
guessing that you know team bridge
itself
as it's as the goal is for the entire
district
i'm guessing teambridge has a very good
working relationship with the key
players that are
uh within the private sector because
teambridge isn't going to
going to achieve this on its own um
and i'm sure there's one out there i
just haven't seen it but if
is there a timetable uh put into place
with the achievable deliverables um
and what those deliverables will will
translate to in terms of carbon
reductions
by 2025 to to to achieve that target
um i was just wondering if if if you
could direct me toward one
are you talking for the district as a
whole now i think you are aren't you i
am talking as the district
oh yeah because because obviously with
the with with the private sector and
team bridge there's a lot of work going
on
but i'm guessing there's a timetable in
place with we need this project
delivered by this time
because this project is going to reduce
the emissions by this much
to go towards our end goal of of of what
this would be in 2025
um and i'm sure that there must be one
that's that's been drawn up because
obviously we've got
we've got a date um so i was just i was
just
yeah i mean that that is what the carbon
action plan will be for the council's
own operation so that's exactly as
you've described it what our carbon
action plan will be
um which you'll which hopefully will
bring to executive in april
in terms of the district as a whole that
that sort of work
is probably um under the devon carbon
plan
um that's where that work is is going on
um and obviously we'll need to put that
down to a team bridge context
and of course you know it's the council
will not be able to do it by itself as
you rightly say that's why we have these
uh really good relationship with action
on climate in
team bridge um but um i don't know if
um william is with us today whether he
just wanted to make any additional
comments
yeah hi um thank you thank you jackie
hook
um yes i just like to echo um
jackie's comments there um so we we are
a partner of the devon climate emergency
group
um so this is a number of um local
authorities
across devon as well as a number of
institutional partners
that are party to that organization
so that that project is ongoing and
there are clear deliverables that that
are set out in the devon carbon plan
um it's important that we don't
duplicate this process
i think it's important also um
that we have a multi-authority
approach um and to make sure that we
bring everybody
up to speed with one sort of united plan
if you like
um we we won't be able to meet uh net
zero
on our own it's it will rely on other
authorities stakeholders businesses
households to all sort of pull together
at the same time
um so the dev income plan is currently
up for consultation
um it will continue to do so until
february 15th on monday
next week um so just encourage you to um
to participate in that if you haven't
already
um anything um that's not included
within the
within the devon carbon plan um and
where we need
a specific action uh for team bridge
itself then we can look to implement
that's ourselves
thank you thank you
um councillor adrian patch please
thank you chair and um thank you um
councillor hope for your presentation
um i will have a look at the devon
carbon plan and it's out for
consultation
that sounds like i'm a document worthy
of having a look at but i just wanted to
ask
whether either yourself or the climate
change officer
or people at devon as far as you're
aware have a routine
of checking and staying updates updated
on the state of the science in terms of
the
the changing climate and in particular
the
relative influence of of natural forcing
versus human influence forcing um
i know it's a fast-moving area and
obviously the the policies that we have
in place are
sort of uh sitting on top of the science
so i'm just interested in really in
in how how tightly that link between
policy and the science
is being monitored and maintained
i'll i don't know if william wants to
come in in a minute but from my point of
view the way we operate is obviously
we're
operating within policies and
legislation that comes down
from from a national context and and
that's and we're
we have our own target of 2025 and we
have above that
um the devon carbon plan eventually and
then obviously various
national legislation and parish climate
agreements and this and the other
and that is what will govern um
what how we need to perform um and
one can only hope that the science um is
taken into account when those policies
and legislations
are put into place i suspect possibly
they're not and they're catching up all
the time and that's where public
pressure comes in
um i don't know if william wanted to
make any comments
yeah so just just further to jackie's
comments there so the the devon common
plan is really centered around
um the committee on climate change uh
their
net zero pathway um so within that the
science is sort of embedded within that
and it's it's based on both existing
technologies
that we understand and know how to
operate presently
and also it'll rely to some extent on
novel technologies that will come
forwards
but that's that net zero pathway is
is continuously under review
and as new technologies innovations
science becomes available
and that that pathway will will become
updated and we can look to
include that in in any net zero pathways
going forwards
okay thank you
thank you i think that's all the
questions um i've got one
it's quite a minor question really um is
team bridge as a council looking at
converting vehicles into electric ones
i know devon enforcement once seemed to
be all
electric now i was wondering whether
there was any plans for that
thank you yes there are that william
comment indeed
in detail but yes yes there are yes i've
been
i have worked with officers from our
fleet services departments
so yes we are looking at electric
vehicles both from
simply purchasing or hiring electric
vehicles into our fleet
um so physically getting the vehicles
into our fleet and also
all of the infrastructure requirements
that um that we require to support those
so currently we don't have a great deal
of electrical supply capacities
at our main sites where we store our
vehicles so ford house the multi-storey
car park
and of course the depot so as part of
the carbon action plan we're looking at
how we can increase
the electrical supply capacities to
those sites and to enable the uptake of
electric vehicles
um we've done some preliminary research
and i sort of
did a rule of thumb calculation on the
amount of electrical opacity that we'd
need to
electrify the entire fleet and it was
something like um three megawatts
um so the equivalent of um three
thousand homes if you like
um all connected at the same time so
clearly there's there's a lot of work
that we need to do to understand
what the network implications are but
we'll we'll bring proposals together as
part of the carbon action plan
um and aim to bring something to
executive sometime around
april this year thank you very much for
that
um i think that's all the questions
okay thank you jackie and william for
that presentation very informative look
forward to getting
the rest of it sent through at a later
date
um right final
item on the agenda which is me
um it's to consider forming
a review group dealing with
the climate and ecological emergency
i presume you've all seen the paperwork
for it i'm not gonna go on too long
um it would be a to establish how town
and parish councils community groups and
other public and voluntary organizations
might better work with the district
council
to support the council's climate changes
and gender
with particular emphasis being given to
ecology and
biodiversity and report back to the ons
committee one on its findings including
potential funding opportunities
and advice for town and parish councils
and community groups and actions they
might wish to take
with support from the district council
um i'd like to propose that by letting
on second
please
uh mr chair i'll do my hand raised oh
sorry didn't say that
come on okay thank you chair um i just
wanted to comment on the document that's
set out
the name of the group um does reflect
the climate and the ecological emergency
um in terms of a task and finishing
group um but the terms of reference
though
uh make explicit reference to the
council's climate change agenda
and then under part a again the climate
change agenda i wonder whether it might
be appropriate to insert
and ecological emergency in both
instances
so for instance the first sentence the
terms of reference as part
of the promotion of the council's
climate change and ecological emergency
agenda
with the same repeated under point a and
i do know that there is a reference to
um sort of the ecology and biodiversity
but i think it would
make sense to include that under the
terms of reference
yeah don't see a problem with that at
all
um yep that's fine i don't
see an issue with that um any other
questions before we go forward
okay i'll propose again if i have a
seconder on that please if possible
thank you adrian um jeff if i may that's
um it's a proposal and seconding
to include ecological emergency in the
terms of reference yes it is yes
um do we it'd be best to do a roll call
on that i think wouldn't it
would it call him no just show off how i
can't anywhere
it's gone on long enough he says i'll
put my end up
okay so all those in favor says one two
three
that's a unanimous chair there's some
eight members
in attendance at the moment and for the
membership
um i propose that it's opened out to
other councillors
um unless we've got everyone on this
group who'd want to
um because i know that there are other
councillors with a
quite strong interest in this subject
that will be
very keen to get involved with this um
i'd like to propose that as a
membership so that's okay let's look in
that chair
thank you very much could we have a hand
show on that one
okay thank you chair that's unanimous
and can we also
um can you also vote on the number the
maximum number
the percent number would be
six oh the other point is sorry i forgot
about that jackie hook
there was a bit of a i'm not quite sure
how that went there
executive member jack counselor jackie
hook will not be a member
there will be six members of
non-executive people
thank you fine
um chair i've got my hand raised again
on this
yep gone uh just in terms of the numbers
and setting a limit
and it does initially come under the
remit of our group
so would it not be um a good idea to see
how many members of our group
would like to be um of our our committee
would like to be members of this group
um and then maybe set the maximum number
accordingly
i mean it would be a shame if given that
this falls under the work area of our
group
if if if there was uh an outcome that
people
on our committee who wanted to be in
that group weren't able to
no that that wouldn't happen agent um it
would be initially
our group and then it would if there
weren't the numbers it would be opened
up to
other other people to make the numbers
up okay thank you for clarifying that
okay thank you chair if i may just just
just to clarify any member
can can can come along to any task and
finish group meeting
uh and and and attend it's just
obviously the core group is made up of
of the initial members
so are we happy with that with
adrian's yeah
chair we just need to have a proposal a
second or two um for the
number of the group
[Music]
yeah that's unanimous thank you chair
thank you i
think that is the end okay thank you
very much for your um
patience and time to support uh this
morning or afternoon now
and um see you at the next one thank you
very much
thank you chairman